McCarthy required
the better part of a week
to grind down the conservative
opposition to his speaker bid
and the way things have been done
in the House for decades.
One of the holdouts,
or Republican Congressman
Chip Roy of Texas,
was instrumental in delivering him
the gavel.
Roy negotiated a laundry list
of concessions
from McCarthy designed to spread power
among the House rank and file
and particularly
the House Freedom Caucus.
And Roy's deal
ultimately flipped up to 15 votes
for McCarthy,
paving the way for his victory
Friday night.
Joining me now for his first interview
after the speaker
election is Texas Republican Congressman
Chip Roy.
First of all, congratulations
on everything that happened
and getting what you wanted
in the negotiations.
It's not it's not necessarily
a sure thing that that that that happens.
We are
just learning some
of the promises McCarthy made,
capping spending at 20,
22 levels for fiscal year 2024,
a subcommittee to investigate
the Justice Department,
more Freedom Caucus
representation on important committees
like the Rules Committee,
a one member threshold
for a motion to vacate,
which is what it used to be before 20.
19.
What other commitments did McCarthy make
you can tell us about?
Well, first of all,
you know,
let's remember that
a little temporary conflict is necessary
in this town
in order to stop this town
from rolling over to the American people.
I don't think anybody
on either
side of the aisle could say
with a straight face
that they think that Washington is doing
good work
for the American people
on a regular basis and isn't broken.
We have to work to fix this place.
And look,
some of the tensions you saw on display
when we saw some of the interactions
there between Mike Rogers and Matt Gates.
You know,
some of that is we need a little of that.
We need a little of this
sort of breaking the glass
in order to get us to the table,
in order to fight
for the American people
and to change the way
this place is dysfunctional.
So this all started going back
last summer.
We wanted rules to open this place up.
We wanted more transparency.
We wanted more openness,
more ability to add
amendments to the force.
For example, you ask,
what else did we get?
We got amendments to be able to ensure
we got the ability
to offer amendments
on the floor of the House
during appropriations
that will open it up again.
We haven't done that.
So since I've been in Congress,
I've not been able
to offer an amendment on the floor.
There hasn't been an amendment
offered an open debate since May of 2016.
Is it if we just roll
like anyone can offer an amendment?
Absolutely. Within appropriations.
We will also be striving
for more open rules.
We put more conservatives,
some Freedom Caucus members
and we're still working through
who those will be on the Rules
Committee, the powerful Rules Committee,
which is the funnel
by which legislation
gets to the floor of the House.
But importantly,
we were trying to stand up
for rank and file members
because too
often and we saw this in December.
Too often bills are cooked up
with a handful of people.
They're brought through the Rules
Committee jammed through,
put on the floor,
and you have to vote yes or no.
The American people are tired of that.
We need to be able
to see some of the stuff
we got to see this week.
You and I were talking
ahead of time cameras
because C-SPAN controlled the cameras.
Are you in favor of that?
Because I love the C-SPAN cameras.
Look,
I think drawing the American people
into the conversation
is the debate on the floor.
I mean, if you're going
to have cameras there,
well, let's look at the action.
Let's see if you're in favor
of transparency.
C-SPAN gets to control it. Well, I would.
Let me go look into the ins
and outs of all of that.
But I think it is
what the American people were able to see
unfold on
the floor
was a good thing for our democracy
and our republic. Right.
It was a good thing for people
to be able to see the inner workings.
And this isn't just the shirts and skins
red and blue, too, team thing.
This is history
because this hasn't happened
in the last hundred years.
But understand why that so
to party entrenchment
has made it to where
we don't have a good back and forth
to sit at the table
and try to accomplish this.
So I'm all in favor of transparency.
I'm a journalist. I want everybody out.
So I hope you'll look into
the C-SPAN thing
because
because I think that really does show
the American people.
I don't think it's a bad thing to show
Democrats and Republicans
tough negotiations, etc.
Will in the name of transparency.
Will you or the Speaker
put out a list
of the concessions of these changes?
Because they're not all, as you know,
they're not all reflected
in the rules
that are going to come up for a vote
this week. Sure.
I mean,
and again, part of this is all sensitive,
right, as you're kind of going through it
and kind of holding everybody together.
We got to get through the rules on Monday
and we're going through
the steering process
of getting folks on committees.
But but for example,
when we say we want it, we put out a list
in, what, December 8th
try saying, hey, here's what we think.
We need to transform this place.
Here's what we need to see
in any speaker.
And so we've been out
and open about that.
But I want to make clear,
this isn't about trying to chip
Roy once a spot on a committee.
I haven't been promised anything.
Literally, I've got nothing out of this
deal for me personally.
Does that mean
I might end up on Rules Committee?
Maybe,
if that's what the my colleagues want
We still have to go through that process.
But what we have
extracted is promises from the speaker
to make sure
that we have ideological diversity
and representation
among these committees. Appropriations.
There are two Freedom
Caucus members out of 33
that are likely to be in the majority.
So think about that.
HFC is 20% of the body
at two of 33 appropriators.
The rules committee.
It's always a struggle
to get anybody on there
who's going to push back in the rules
Committee about
wait why are we jamming a bill
through that nobody's read right.
So let's let's get representation
on these committees
and and
it's not about petty personal desires.
I don't want to be on the rules
committee.
I want to leave my family on Sunday night
and miss my kids to come up here.
But I might do it
if that's what my colleagues decide.
So let me ask you a question
about whether or not the
whatever you want to call it, the
chaos, the back and forth,
whether or not this is going
to mark
what the Congress is going to look like
going forward over the next two years.
McCarthy promised
one of the promises
was not to raise the debt ceiling
without some accompanying spending cuts.
Correct.
Congress had a similar showdown
trying to force spending cuts in 2011.
It led to America's credit
rating getting downgraded
because the
because they weren't able
to arrive at the deal
the markets felt the U.S.
government had become
according to the downgrade
and quote
less stable, less effective,
less predictable
and that had a real tangible
detrimental effect
on the American people
and their pocketbooks,
their retirement savings.
What's the plan
to make sure that doesn't happen again
that the chaos
we saw this week or whatever you
want to call it
doesn't become
just what happens every time,
especially when we're talking about
major must-pass legislation
like raising the debt ceiling,
which is just about paying the bills
for what has already been paid.
Well, the fastest way to guarantee
that we have debt
rating problems is to keep spending money
we don't have and keep piling up debt.
And that's what we're doing.
The unique party in Washington,
Republicans
and Democrats, the powerbrokers,
which, by the way,
were reflected by Mike Rogers
when he goes in and he's pushing
back on the bill, says,
I will finish you. Right.
So why is that?
Because when you push back on the swamp,
the swamp is going to push right back.
We saw that in display.
That's okay.
So you said, well,
are we going to have
this kind of conflict going forward?
I hope so.
But we started this.
Now it's January.
So the debt ceiling debate
is going to be in a few months.
Let's do it now, guys.
Let's get this out there.
Both sides of the aisle,
everybody within each party.
Let's figure out
how we're going to actually fix this,
because the American
people are sick of us not doing our job.
There is a bigger risk, though,
for the U.S.
defaulting on the debt ceiling
when it comes to the debt ceiling vote.
Then some short
term embarrassment
for Kevin McCarthy, that's
the default is a bigger deal
and could actually cost
billions of dollars. Understood.
But remember in 2011 when that cut,
cap and balance was negotiated
and put in place
and frankly
it worked for four or five years
to constrain spending now
it had some side effects.
Defense spending
was getting whacked pretty good.
And we don't want to see that
we want to be able
to figure out how we can get this going
the right way
to make sure our defense is protected.
But we need to put limits on spending
and then get to the table.
You have to do that at home, Jake.
I have to do that at home.
Every American has to do that.
If we don't stop spending money
we don't have.
I promise you,
we will never sit at the table.
Collin All right.
Who's going to be on here
a little bit that I was talking to
in the green room column.
And I need to be able to sit at a table
and figure out
how we're going to fix this
for the country.
We can't do that if the leaders
jam through $1.7 trillion omnibus bills
like happened in December, right.
Where we have no debate on the floor.
We have to open this debate
up, offer amendments,
do our work,
limit spending within our means,
and then move the country forward.
If McCarthy fails to offer a debt
ceiling bill that has offsetting
spending cuts,
if he offers
what the Democrats in the Senate want,
which is a clean bill,
would you vote to vacate the speakership?
Because they will now
be able to be one person
making that motion to take the speaker?
Look, I'm not going to
you know, I'm
not going to play the What-If games
on how we're going to use
the tools of the House
to make sure that we enforce
the terms of the agreement,
but we will use the tools of the House
to enforce the terms of the agreement.
No, you negotiate
with Democrats in the Senate
because as you know. Sure.
This isn't just about you
negotiating with Kevin McCarthy.
Kevin McCarthy is much more conservative.
Sure.
However much
you think he is actually a conservative
compared to the people
who run the Senate,
which are the Democrats
or the White House, which is Joe Biden.
Right.
Well, remember,
that in 2011,
Obama was in the White House
and we got cut, cap and balance
because we took it
to the American people.
The American people were tired
of the status quo.
We took the message to them
and we force change.
Our point is let's fight
now to end the status quo.
Let's get in the rooms now.
Republicans should send
good appropriations
bills over to the House.
Make Chuck Schumer reject them.
Let's send a good appropriations bill
funding our men and women in uniform.
Who you so great.
I'm grateful that you support them
so much.
Let's go send them a good bill.
Let's go send a good homeland
security bill.
Let's go send legislation.
If Chuck Schumer doesn't
want to pass those, then it's on him.
Let's come back to the table
and let's talk about it.
But let's do our part
to balance the budget,
do our job,
and put everything on the table
for everybody
to sit down
and do the work of the American people
in these talks, in these negotiations.
Did Kevin McCarthy
or his emissaries ever say anything
when it came to cuts or caps on Medicare
and Social Security?
So what we're talking about here,
just as everybody knows
is setting spending at the f y.
22 levels,
which would be, what, $1.471 trillion.
And then let's all sit down
and figure out
how we're going to go, all of it.
So what will let's sit down
and how we're going to spend on that
discretionary spending.
What we've been very clear about
is we're not going to touch the benefits
that are going to people
relying on the benefits
under Social Security, Medicare.
But we all have to be honest
about sitting at the table
and figuring out
how we're going to make those work,
how we're going to deal
with defense spending
and how we're going to deal
with non-defense discretionary spending.
But we've got to spend with our whole
spending within our means.